bonjour marcel tel side bonjour muzio le
temps bonjour jolie de tous de la
première vous êtes le nom de ce groupe
de réflexion patriotes du milliard matin
vous étiez sous les hauteurs de la
démarche h el cheikh pour justifier
encore une fois votre recours à
l'encontre de l'actuelle direction du
mouvement indépendantiste martiniquais
on rappelle que le lit mais désormais
sous administration judiciaire suite à
ce recours et qu'on attend une assemblée
générale appelée de tous vos voeux par
vous par vos compagnons d'ici quatre
mois maximum en celtel side
avez vous l'impression que votre action
a été comprise maintenant par tout le
monde
oui depuis un moment nous réalisons que
le vent a indiqué comprend ce que nous
on veut à ce moment en effet il y a que
notre président depuis un moment et et
ben il réagit à sa manière il a agi à sa
manière il prend des décisions qui ne
sont pas les siennes et puis l'autre
problème c'est que partout il voit le
complot il voit la traîtrise à chaque
pas mieux qu'à trouver un moule à face
les lignes à bas etc ok oui il n'y a pas
que lui a parlé de traîtrise de complot
puisque le secrétaire général à
l'organisation parle de vous comme étant
des traîtres également oui alors ça
c'est malheureux et j'ai souvent dit que
finalement daniel malicier n'est pas
alfred mongy il se cache derrière le
président je ne sais point pourquoi je
ne sais pas quand ça qu'ils se touchent
la vie est un moment à un moment j'ai
été membre du comité national à une
époque et jambes donc quand il a fallu
rajeunir le rom du national quand il a
fallu aussi mettre un peu de mixité et
bien nous sommes tout un goût bulli noir
enfin tout un beau avoir tout simplement
laisser nos plats les historiques comme
vous croyez vous avoir
nous sommes le terrain patty est à
présent tu as dit que ni en sorte de
dérive autocratique autres l'échangé
simple il y aura des élections d'ici
quatre mois
qu'est ce qui vous a été posée hier
marcel tel sida vous et à votre groupe
pourquoi faire tout cela si vous n'avez
aucunement l'intention de proposer un
candidat ils pourraient 3 l'été qui
pourrait renouveler le mode de
fonctionnement de ce parti c'était salon
d'aujourd'hui notamment des deux
personnes nous pagny place personne
apprend le mignan statut ni un mode de
fonctionnement que nous te connaître que
toute une collecte est bonne on aime
tout simplement que la direction
actuelle où viennent cette dépression
bon franchement en toute conscience
konya baguet qui ait changé même si leur
souhaitant une belle coûte l'épée dans
et puis il raconte à la bombe
effectivement nous qu'à attendre ça mais
ma salle de cardio que connaissant et
puis pour avoir entendu les réactions
qui de daniel marie-sainte qui d'alfred
marie jeanne - pagny l'idée que à
échanger croire tout ça pour ça tout ça
pour rien tout ça va boire un bon mais
affable et 20 rebonds mi mai kb home is
no doubt est atone article a dit aussi
que
non seulement aux autres qu'à mendier
assemblée générale pour faire le point
sur yon de baqem et autres évoqué assez
longuement hier à côté la démarche à
faire communion comité national qui
cabinet en sorte de commission bis de la
collectivité territoriale de barry knapp
pas capable par exemple de l'idéologie
encore ouais mais c'est simple on note
aujourd'hui que des piles acides gras
s'était même installé nous aujourd'hui
que le mime s'est passé
mimouni la chasse de trappes et la
direction de trouver que nous qu'à
diriger la ctm mais le mouvement
indépendantiste martiniquais cas utile
mouvement indépendantiste martiniquais
et puis un certain nombre d'instances à
times m et puis en tant qu ils me font
penser fondamental le mime c'est m où
nous tous je dis est faux mais mobiliser
et informer éduquer mobiliser et
organiser ici pacioretty à la sécheresse
d'émulation on dirait que ni démon qui
doivent battre mario albano mais qui
sert qu'à palais tout cas le conseil
national en mai nous parlera les locales
ou internationales et d'ailleurs pas une
pièce instance katia n'auront alors
recommandé donc élections pour assemblée
générale demandé également que yom et et
anticoup didier hassoux les finances
sont ni des soupçons et ni non et vous
ça ce n'est pas nous ces images en
disent à qui en disant les ouais mais
les new town layton comme
l'administration judiciaire pour
récupérer la comptabilité
mouvement indépendantiste martiniquais
janvier 2011
c'est pour ça qu'il sera long mais c'est
normal le minbar assorti adam statut les
associations donc locales ici vrai
l'argent de l'état local si la
cotisation et/ou mis en mots nyabou
gérer l'argent et à côté ça est bien née
des assemblées justement assemblée
générale association qui la crypte où
collège ni connaissance de l'état
trésorerie associations 1 2 timonier aux
cages et là j'en ai eu
donc c'est ça justement dans le top 6 3
ne pas jamais dit que le joueur jean
bien aimé ni ni ni ni malfaçons donne
alors y opposer aux questions
accueillait le matin marcel tel si
d'aucuns ont recours actuellement à la
sphère l'actuelle présidence du
mouvement indépendantiste martiniquais
sauf que pagny pièces assemblées
générales des pays 2011
c'est finalement le minipak à exister
conseil neutre a dit non que représente
la wii c'est pas parce que les instances
par catherine groleau que association en
bagage et de la peur à valle di dou da
kg rend pas qu'à exister même si debbie
2011 pagne assemblée générale le même
vivant est né un certain nombre de monde
que nous connaître quitter les kits et
motive les pouvoirs et prérogatives way
jeudi à s'avouer que you to my name is a
man's womb la seiu qui nous vend ses
eaux qui doivent en même temps contre
n'y avait sûrement qu'à poser comme un
psy pour ni en assemblée générale si
pour une élection par l'assemblée
générale d'un canidé monica est votée en
général ou qu'à voter les cotisations à
jourdain mais ça manque au poignet
d'après 16h10
moniot wi fi des cotisations oui il
paraît qu'un idée mais nous aurions
refusé cotation alors problème c'est que
trésorier là qu'il a actuellement
lui-même y mêlant ginza chaque fois tom
lagache ab - puisque sandra oh les
statuts lemine a donné des zones
yemmouni cément bourrier statut a dénié
statut la bouffe et iban ou au madame
tard à démissionner depuis un moment
donc ni à leurs réseaux et jeudi ils
étaient beaucoup mieux en assemblée
d'aqoba côté mes premiers l'assemblée
générale qui qu'a donc tout ça qui fait
illégalement tout ça qu'a fait
légèrement voire donc tout ce qu'a fait
illégalement là je dois dire qu'avec
illégalement
donc ça c'est l'uruguay qui j'achète un
maillot c'est bien tombé
alors ils posent d'autres questions
encore ni de fortes chances que alfred
marie-jeanne rivierez prison des cayes
oui d'après sam entreprenautes paquet
présenté pièce candidats statistiquement
il ya une chose que alfred marie-jeanne
virer tous les présidents le mouvement
indépendantiste martiniquais mais est
prêt si l'aja après mais c'est ici qu'on
prenne sa nou ka mandé a et celles ci
comprennent ça la justice car jusqu'à ce
jour nous et le mouvement
indépendantiste martiniquais mais
amandine pourquoi les mollahs
oui et puis c'est à dire aussi que
alfred marie-jeanne soit vous quittez
parlementaire pendant quatre mandats
dont qui s'assagit que la loi le respect
de la loi puisqu'il a déjà des idées de
calcul hawaï de café les amendements des
donc il connaît pas et nous en veulent
ça c'était le site vie de l'ex terrestre
panier pression que tout s'assemble
vagabondage et en tout cas les autres
que tout le monde car is hot
non
mme amara passé comme galinou ni un
certain nombre de bombes et des mungiki
des fanatiques un tic acquis 4 été non
plus d'être de traître tous conviennent
d'affaires 4 était de 2 mais ça ne peut
pas être la main en vagabondage et les
autres tout comme on y écoute villes
comme cali seaway qu'à dix mois que nous
en lambeaux gmail
très bien merci marcel tels sites du
groupe de réflexion patriotes 10 min
merci d'avoir été dans son édition datée
bonne journée
[Musique]